weighing in at 200,000 kilos and
stretching the length of a basketball
court
the blue whale tops the big animal
charts now researchers think the
seasonal availability of its forty
million krill a day diet may have led to
their behemoth size what does the fossil
record say researchers knew from living
whale proportions that the size of a
whale correlates with the width of its
cheek bones they then measured skulls of
63 extinct whale species and 13 modern
species and plotted them on a timeline
that showed the whale family tree
the whales didn't get to be really big
early on nor did they gradually get
bigger over time instead they became
moderately large and stayed that way
until about 4.5 million years ago then
baleen whales went from relatively big
to ginormous 4.5 million years ago the
biggest whales were only ten meters long
today
blue whales are 30 meters what was
happening 4.5 million years ago it was
the beginning of the first ice ages and
as glaciers expanded spring and summer
runoff poured lots of nutrients into the
coastal ocean fueling explosive growth
of whale food that seasonal runoff
created a new pattern of food
availability seasonal patches very
abundant food spaced far apart for the
course of the year why would that make
for bigger whales modern whale studies
show that the more concentrated the food
the greater the feeding efficiency
especially in whales with really big
mouths furthermore larger whales can
travel faster between patches of prey so
baleen whales that got
bigger faster thrived while smaller
species went extinct so for whale
evolution it's not quite you are what
you eat but close
[Music]